tu non sei solo
queste sono le parole più importanti che
possiamo dire e sentirci dire hanno una
forza e una magia che altre parole non
hanno talmente tanto che non serve
nemmeno contesto non serve conoscersi
per dircele
hanno un potere che va al di là del loro
stesso significato e che altre frasi non
hanno quale ci crediamo
se io te le dico ci credi per un attimo
ma è così posso fare degli esempi
contrari se io dico ti amo
oppure no non ti ho tradito o in una
splendida imitazione di mia madre jeans
buttati jeans strappati io non ho
buttato nessun paio di jeans strappati
li avranno persi lavanderia
ecco queste sono cose alle quali tu non
necessariamente credi ma se io ti guardo
negli occhi al bar al mare al parco alla
fermata dell'autobus all'ufficio postale
e ti dico tu non sei sola tu non sei
solo tu mi credi così istantaneamente
eppure non le diciamo mai né agli altri
nè a noi stessi perché
cos'è la solitudine la solitudine può
essere l'esclusione da ogni rapporto di
vicinanza e presenza altrui
ricercata come motivo di pace o intimità
sofferta se conseguente all'assenza di
ogni affetto sostegno e conforto in
parole più povere ce la possiamo
immaginare la solitudine come un
ambiente uno spazio inabitato deserto
pervaso da una sconfinata
inospitale vastità
vista cos'è la solitudine allora vediamo
cosa non è la solitudine la solitudine
non è assenza
senza non è solitudine non sono la
stessa cosa se io ti dico non trovo i
miei jeans strappati i miei jeans
strappati sono certamente assenti non
necessariamente sono soli perché
potrebbero essere nelle mani di chi li
ha presi ma se io ti dico tu hai preso e
buttato senza dirmelo i miei jeans
strappati allora forse ti sto dicendo
che mi stai facendo sentire sola e mi
stai anche facendo sentire quanto siamo
distanti di più ogni giorno che passa
questo era quello che pensavo io durante
l'adolescenza di non poter scegliere di
stare da sola ma di continuare
incessantemente a sentirmici sola perché
il distacco dalle figure genitoriali e
in generale da chi si prende cura di noi
non è importante e fondamentale
ci sono diverse fasi della vita doveva
fatto ci si deve di staccare grandi
pensatori studiosi della mente dicono
che metaforicamente si dovrebbero
uccidere i genitori
metaforicamente
però mi hai rubato i miei jeans e mihai
buttati a me
quando ci troviamo
nelle situazioni della vita dove dovremo
di staccarci dalla nostra famiglia a
volte falliamo e se falliamo non potendo
cene andare non possiamo tornare
cresciuti maturi adulti grandi quindi
poi non siamo in grado di impostare
paletti e recinti all'interno delle
nostre relazioni con la famiglia e con
gli altri recinti che servono a tutelare
il nostro io per concederlo quando noi
siamo in grado di farlo non quando ci
viene chiesto se falliamo ci spezziamo
in due il nostro cuore si rompe e il
nostro cervello metaforicamente si
spacca in due parti una è quella che
vediamo tutti che è più o meno capace
buona giusta onesta
l'altra è nascosta da una parte che noi
abbiamo deciso essere senza speranza la
prima parte sa stare al mondo la seconda
parte il mondo lo soffre fino al midollo
la prima parte va all'ufficio postale
parla con l'impiegato telefono al
ristorante per prenotare una cena parla
con l'amministratore di condominio e ci
discute per la lampadina al terzo piano
che ancora fulminata e fa due
chiacchiere con la madre di marco fuori
scuola quando accompagna i figli la
seconda parte di noi è terrorizzata
dalla porta scorrevole dell'ufficio
postale non si sente all'altezza di fare
nessuna telefonata nemmeno al ristorante
odia il confronto detesta il contrasto e
non importa che siano genitori o figli
non si sente all'altezza di nessuno
immaginiamo le queste due parti la prima
vede le persone sa di far parte di un
gruppo comprende il rapporto di presenza
e vicinanza altrui
la seconda vede le persone ma è immersa
in un ambiente nell'assenza assoluta di
ogni rapporto d'affetto sostegno e
conforto
pervasa da un senso di sconfinata e
inospitale vastità
la prima parte sa stare da sola la
seconda si sente sola
noi non diciamo mai a nessuno nè a noi
stessi tu non sei solo tu non sei sola
perché c'è una parte di noi che vive con
noi e viaggiaconnoi appesantita da ogni
singolo istante quella parte di noi che
tutti i giorni a un certo punto arriva e
dice tu non vali abbastanza se ti hanno
lasciato c'è un motivo è colpa tua di
tutto dovevi fare di più nella vita ma
concederti meno noi donne dovevamo darla
a tutti ma poi riprendercela noi uomini
dovevamo essere migliori con le donne ma
mai perché in questa parte
non nascondiamo le nostre difese che
sono identitarie di genere di razza
politiche religiose e sono razziste sono
omo lesbo b transfobiche grasso fobiche
abili stesse noto be perché come ci si
difende dal mondo se sempre colpa tua
noi nascondiamo questa parte di noi e
noi non diciamo tu non sei solo tu non
sei sola perché non abbiamo la minima
idea che quello dall'altra a parte della
strada impiegato all'ufficio postale
quello che risponde al telefono e prende
le prenotazioni al ristorante e la mamma
di marco dentro hanno la stessa parte
spezzata hanno la stessa parte rotta e
questo è il motivo della solitudine
sapere di avere una parte di te che
nessuno ama perché nessuno conosce
perché nessuno vede questo è il problema
della solitudine
ci sentiamo soli perché non ci sentiamo
amati e non ci sentiamo amati perché per
credere all'amore di qualcuno deve
avergli detto chi sei sapere di avergli
detto io sono così per intero sapere che
ama le tue mani ma anche le tue mani e
lo fanno sorridere perché sono due ma
entrambe piccole che adora i tuoi occhi
ma anche i tuoi desideri perché anche
quelli sono due ma grandi noi non ci
crediamo quando le persone ci dicono che
ci amano perché non gli abbiamo fatto
vedere chi siamo
non lo facciamo mai perché abbiamo una
paura delle nostre debolezze
delle nostre parti sporche delle nostre
abitudini delle nostre ridicole
ossessioni per le bambole di porcellana
per i giochi di ruolo con i pupazzetti
per i pantaloni senza gli strappi quando
eravamo piccoli le nostre famiglie non
ci hanno aiutato a distaccarci per
alcuni di noi era chiaro il messaggio se
te ne vai io non sarò mai più felice
però altri di noi è stato ancora più
complicato tornare cresciuti perché
nessuno li stava aspettando
e poi c'è un altro gruppo quello più
numeroso che dei genitori li hanno avuti
ma così terribili da fargli scontare a
cinghiate schiaffi abusi e umiliazioni e
vergogna ogni goccia della loro
infelicità in felicità di chi li aveva
messi al mondo che ancora si vede
perfettamente in una mappa di cicatrici
sul corpo di chi l'ha ricevuta
cicatrici così profonde dentro e fuori
che certe ancora si vedono e certe altre
anche perché le cicatrici si vedono
tutte e per sempre e per questo gli
psicoterapeuti dovrebbero essere
ricercati e desiderati quanto i
chirurghi plastici
fatto sta che è da allora che noi
torniamo a casa tutte le sere come se
fosse un costume di scena c sfiliamo di
dosso la persona che mostriamo per
diventare la persona che ci fa paura ci
mettiamo davanti allo specchio ci
guardiamo e diciamo ma chi l'ha amerebbe
mai una figura così rotta
è da allora che abbiamo deciso che tutte
le parti di noi che sono sbagliate non
perfette non spolverate non lucide non
precise non profumate accoglienti e
funzionali non vanno bene e vanno
nascoste la verità siamo tutti rotti
abbiamo tutti un pigiama di merda perché
è brutto andare a dormire tutte le sere
non sapendo se il problema sei tu o la
persona che hai nascosto così in fondo
da essere quasi tatuata sulla tua pelle
ma la verità è che siamo tutti rotti e
quelle due parti di te che tu proprio
non riesci a far comunicare io le vedo
perché le ho anch'io e così tutti quelli
con i quali di rapporti la mattina il
pomeriggio la sera al telefono fuori da
scuola dentro il tuo condominio siamo
tutti rotti e quindi comincio io oggi a
dirti tu non sei solo tu non sei solo e
vorrei che facesse la stessa cosa che
faccio io sapendo che c'è una differenza
da oggi che per ogni volta nella quale
nelle tue parti distrutte ti sei
mangiato le unghie fino a far uscire il
sangue la tua vicina di casa si
strappava le ciglia vorrei che tutti
ricordassi che tutte le volte nelle
quali hai deciso di aprire un account
fake per dire a qualcuno sei un grasso
bastardo semplicemente perché eri
arrabbiato per un altro motivo il tuo
capo ufficio cercava continuamente di
aprire la portiera della macchina dopo
averla chiusa con l'allarme vorrei dirti
che tutte le volte che sei tornato è
tornata a casa e hai detto guardando al
cielo perché mi lasciano tutti dio ti
prego dimmi perché nessuno mi ama i
genitori di marco si stavano urlando le
cose peggiori senza avere il respiro di
dirsi l'unica cosa che gli faceva paura
siamo tutti rotti quindi oggi comincio
io a dirtelo quello che dico alle mie
due parti tutte le mattine io mi merito
l'amore perché non è colpa mia da dove
rally ma è mia meravigliosa
responsabilità dove sto andando
non è colpa tua da dove vieni ma è tua
meravigliosa responsabilità dove stai
andando fai vedere agli altri chi sei e
troverai qualcuno che lo ama per intero
perché lo condivide con te ovviamente a
meno che tu odi gli strappi nei jeans in
quel caso meriti la solitudine
mostra gli altri chi sei perché queste
due parti ce le abbiamo anche noi non è
colpa tua da dove vieni ma il tua
meravigliosa responsabilità dove stai
andando e sinceramente io vorrei l'onore
di venire con te perché così almeno
saremo in due o in quattro se ci andiamo
spezzati a rendere quella desolata terra
sconfinata una cazzo di festa
[Applauso]